jetzt bin ich mal gespannt welches die
hässlichste Stadt Deutschlands sein soll
meiner Meinung nach safe Duisburg
Wolfsburg Wolfsburg kommen wer hat das
Ranking denn erstellt das ist doch
wolfsburg ist zwar jetzt Müll vor allem
der Fußballverein aber es ist schon ganz
schön gebaut ist ja auch viel neu und so
da ist so ein Outlet absoluter Quatsch
also da gibt's viel hässlichere Städte
okay fangen wir mit dem positiven an der
VW-Konzern versucht wirklich alles um
den Menschen das Leben in dieser Stadt
schmackhaft zu machen so gibt es
unglaublich viel Kultur Kunst und
natürlich auch Sport dafür dass die
Stadt relativ klein ist der Nachteil
Wolfsburg wurde halt irgendwann für die
Arbeiter des VW Werkes errichtet und
genauso sieht es auch aus es ist ein
städtebaulicher Albtraum der 50er und
60er Jahre mit ganz ganz viel Beton ja
weiß ich nicht also ich bin einmal in
Wolfsburg so rumgelaufen ich fand es
jetzt nicht schlimm also ich habe schon
viel viel schlimmeres gesehen in
Deutschland viel viel schlimmer